the third richest place in the world is
after America and China is nowhere
because there are man's written a book
on it and it's very very interesting
because of shell companies that have
been created by a German banker who is
living in England and then enabled by
the English banking system which can do
so many wonderful things and it means
that now this third richest place is
absolutely nowhere in the world and
there are people in Japan and China so
if you are a very wealthy Chinese
businessman you can use a surrogate
mother in Japan to have your baby born
in Japan so it doesn't look like a
citizen of China so you put all your
money into that child and your child is
your shell company and money all over
the world is floating around in this
land and it's touching no one and it
really matters and it matters because
where money is pouring means that
increasingly we touch physically touch
humans less we say hello to them less we
go out and meet them less and it means
that in places like London there are
people who did not know that there were
people who didn't like globalization and
so they held this nice vote to see if
we'd like to go if we still want to be
part of this nice Europe where we all go
on holiday in the summer and and sit in
Italy and they were staggered to realize
that there were people in Britain who
didn't go on holiday to the
Mediterranean and didn't want to be part
of Europe and so all foreigners is a
little bit dangerous
of course Theresa May said when she took
on the mantle of leading the BRICS it
which is probably regretting quite a bit
these days she was complaining about
those people who think her citizens of
everywhere and hence mere citizen of
nowhere I'm actually a proud citizen of
nowhere I warned off my an actual
insignia on my passport and I'm pretty
fine with that
but it's a different nowhere from there
nowhere you describe the nowhere you
described is very much very nowhere of
abstraction but there is also no where
Teresa may was complaining about and
that's probably where I'm sitting these
people who actually feel like yeah I can
switch countries I actually do feel not
exactly beholden
a state because a state to me is just
like my phone company it's a tool what
she wanted and what naturalist want is
of course they want the emotional
feeling a connection and this is of
course where it actually gets to be
human level what kind of connection do
you have I belong to a particular tribe
academic tribe and I feel at home at
universities on both hemispheres but
that's very different from the tribe
some other people belong to and
understanding and managing this in a
globalized world is getting very tricky
you